legend has it that one day a new king
will come
[Music]
who will use the power of the Trident to
put Atlantis back together one can
is the exact spot that Volkl gave me my
first woman lesson no not even close you
have to forget all the teaching of the
surface world go deeper one covering
your Atlantean instincts
he spent his entire life training
they need to be the best
my parents made me what I am
I'm the protector of the deep
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis in the romance it would bring
destruction but in the hands of the true
heir
it would unite above and below the time
has come for mantis to rise again
mas talkin about he proposed me 2,000 by
retrieving this early Elmo's not like
this one you don't the war is coming to
the service whether you like it or not
my mother always knew you were special
you believe
you'd be the one to unite out to world
he's always had a king
now I need something more
a wall could be greater than a king
here
[Music]
you
you